you know how many feet there are in a
mile 3 000 something this is the moment
I realized I will never use the metric
system okay let's see how far you can
drop ready my six-year-old is constantly
asking me to measure how far he can jump
on that okay oh I'm gonna count it ready
set and inevitably this ends up
happening okay stay there stay there one
two three that was two meters no it was
six no remember you got oh six feet yeah
oh
[Music]
the entire world uses the same measuring
system except for three countries so you
have the richest most powerful country
and then you have this small African
nation that the U.S kind of invented to
like ship slaves back to it's a weird
situation that I made a whole video
about totally different and then you
have Myanmar a Southeast Asian country
that used to be called Burma you don't
see maps like this very often where the
whole world is one color and then you
have three random countries peppered
across the globe that are a different
color and I'm looking at you Britain I
know that you're green on this map but
we all know you still kind of dabble in
pounds and Pints and Miles I want to
show you exactly how this happened and
show you why I will never use the metric
system if somebody runs a 5k I have no
idea what that translates into miles a
thousand two-step Paces of a Roman
soldier we have no reason to be ashamed
for using feet pounds now many
calculations are merely a matter of
moving the decimal point it's one of the
great things about Americans is we won't
change no matter how good it would be
for us
[Applause]
hey real quick we'll get back to metric
in just a second but I need to think
today's sponsor because that's how I run
a business so that I can make these
videos for you the sponsor of today's
video is nordvpn which is a brand that
has supported this channel for a long
time now and I'm very grateful a VPN is
a thing that sounds really fancy and
Technical but it basically just allows
you to connect to the internet via a
different country this is useful for a
lot of reasons I've been traveling a lot
lately and I've been able to use nordvpn
to connect to my internet via the United
States so that all of my Gmail and
accounts don't think that I'm like a
hacker in a different country this is
very very useful to me especially in the
world of endless two-factor
authentication death Loops that I've
been in many times when I'm in other
countries it's amazing how a little
affordable tool can just fix that and
that's what nordvpn does oh and by the
way it's not some like coding Tech boy
thing you just literally press a button
and you're like connected to a VPN it
also works the other way if I'm in the
United States and want to connect to the
internet met via Canada or the UK or
India I suddenly get access to all of
the things that Canadians and British
people see when they like log onto
Netflix it's pretty cool oh and nordvpn
also has this new thing called threat
protection which basically when it's
turned on you can surf the Internet and
not worry about trackers and malicious
ads and malware and all of these things
that you just don't want to worry about
when you're on the internet so there's a
link in my description it's nordvpn.com
Johnny Harris clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you in on an exclusive deal where you
can sign up for nordvpn and get four
months for free oh and you get 30 days
to decide if you are going to use this
or not and if it's useful to you and you
can get all of your money back if it's
not
pretty good deal let's get back to why I
will never use the metric system
the first thing humans measured was time
think of like sun moon stars sundials
constellations this was pretty easy
because we're all looking up at the same
night sky it basically does the same
thing every day and every night totally
reliable and unchanging measuring stuff
like weight and length is way harder and
for a long time the best thing we had
was our bodies humans are about this big
so we've always wanted a unit of
measurement about this law the earliest
unit of measurement that we know of is
the qubit which was basically the length
of a forearm not super precise because
we all have different sized forearms but
I got the job done at least in the case
of building giant Pyramids in Cairo or
in Noah's Ark which was apparently 300
of these puppies over time humans needed
to measure bigger and longer things so
they began using their daily activities
as references which was mostly just like
a lot of farming like the acre which was
the amount of of land that a farmer
could manage to plow in a day or the
hundredweight which was kind of how much
a man could carry on his back
comfortably because yeah it's the same
for everyone right let's say you Corey
Ma
wait so by the 1700s there was like a
billion ways of measuring things but up
here they had a few popular ones so
you've got the foot which was well the
average length of a man's foot this is a
ruler that you always have handy with
you handy
hand foot handy
right
should we keep that
[Music]
and then you've got the inch which in
the 1300s was decreed as three grains of
barley laid end to end from the midst of
the ear right who knows what a barley
corn is super convenient right
we need to measuring tape when you could
just bring around a little pouch of all
your barley corns to measure things with
and then there was the yard which was
like the average measurement around
someone's chest
and then King Henry shows up in England
and is like we need to standardize the
yard using my body and for a while there
in England it was King Henry's body like
the length from his nose to his thumb or
like the length of his arm that was used
to derive all of these like yard-like
measurements it was his literal body
like that's what they were using and
then there's the mile which is the
distance covered by Roman soldiers
walking 1 000 Paces they then somehow
discovered that the mile was roughly
about eight furlongs furlongs of course
being the distance that a team of oxen
could plow without resting the pound was
defined as the weight of 7 000 grains
987 6988
oh this is really terrible what is
happening I mean all of these
measurements seem so tenuous and
inconsistent and they were six thousand
nine hundred and ninety nine seven
thousand we've got a pound everyone we
got a pound it was Madness
[Music]
meanwhile down here in France in the
late 1700s they were dealing with their
own Madness and it had nothing to do
with measurements at this time the
French were beheading kings and queens
and they were drinking lots of coffee
and sitting around in salons doing
science things the people of France
wanted to change just about everything
and the measurement systems were not off
the table in these discussions so in the
middle of all of this Enlightenment they
look at each other and they're like why
the hell are we using our forearms to
measure stuff they needed something
precise it's not like barley corns and
forearms but something that they could
Peg their new measurement system to that
was an unchanging Baseline
how about the literal planet we live on
said the coffee drinking French science
guys we should measure this distance
right here and divide it by 10 a bunch
of times and get a really precise unit
of measure so that we don't have to use
our feet and arms great idea but how the
hell do you get this massive measurement
in 1792 and the answer was this thing
plus some math so these two French
astronomers go out into the French
Countryside looking for high up places
like Hills or like Castle Towers and
then they looked through this fancy
little Platinum math telescope and
measure the angles between two points
out in the distance this fancy telescope
allows them to make this measurement
without having to walk these whole
distances and in this way they could
start making little triangles across the
French Countryside and then using some
basic math that we all learned in middle
school they could start to calculate a
hyper accurate distance along this
straight line it took them seven years
to calculate all of this but they got it
and once they had this distance they
were able to calculate this distance
between the North Pole and the equator
one-fourth of the Earth's circumference
so they took this line This measurement
and they chopped it up into 10 million
little parts and one of those parts is
called a meter like this is pegged to a
real unchanging measurement that is our
Earth I mean it'll change eventually
but not in our lifetimes the name meter
comes from the Greek word Metron which
means a measurement which is just like
super literal and precise in exactly
what the french Enlightenment was all
about now here's what it's all about
the meter so now you have this meter and
if you divide this into a hundred
smaller units you have a centimeter
centimeter so put a thousand of these
side by side and you get yourself a
kilometer a kilometer the best part
about the metric system is the time it
saves in computation wait a minute I can
do this it's all about tens so if this
measurement was 10 million of these
divide that by a thousand you get 10 000
kilometers okay so this is ten thousand
kilometers
one-fourth of the Earth circumference
four of these should be
40 000 kilometers
circumference is 40 000 kilometers
wait what no I don't want miles come on
what it should be forty thousand what's
this extra 75 kilometers doing here well
it turns out that one of these French
astronomers actually made an error in
his calculations making the final meter
about 0.2 millimeters shorter than it
should have been the guy quickly
discovered this like in the middle of it
but he didn't tell anyone because
support for this new system was already
really tenuous and you didn't want
anyone to have any more doubt or
skepticism so it turns out the metric
system isn't literally perfect take that
finding this measurement was the hardest
part now that they have it they were
able to build an entire system purely
based off of this let me show you okay
so now we want a unit for volume let's
build a hypothetical Cube that is 10
centimeters on all sides to fill it up
with liquid and you have a liter one
liter and from there you can do the same
thing that we did with meters
centiliters kiloliters you name it it's
all 10 which makes it so much easier to
convert between these different
measurements it's a lot easier than
Barleycorns okay so now we have a leader
which is a volume thing let's use this
to make a unit for mass AKA weight
I know they're different but it's like
the Earth's gravity makes white and mass
the same when you're written on Earth
blah blah blah I get it commenters I see
you I see you typing right now back off
you fill this leader with water and now
you have a kilogram divide that by a
thousand and you have a gram add a
thousand kilograms together and you have
a metric ton I mean it's simple it's
tens it's hundreds of thousands now many
calculations are merely a matter of
moving the decimal point
not the pencil
okay so now they have all these units
that are scientific and standardized and
founded on concepts of exact
measurements and this is really the
first time that humans ever had this the
Frenchmen all looked at each other and
the good work guys we did it the coffee
helped this is great what should we call
it and they settled on
[Music]
okay cool great system but why don't I
use the metric system what happened
well that has to do with pirates and
international politics so France is like
this system works pretty damn well we're
impressed with ourselves we should tell
the rest of the world both paste so it's
the late 1700s and France is going
around country by country with a literal
meter stick being like hey guys look
what we invented it's Peg to the Earth
it's like literally like we measured
this entire thing and you should adopt
it because it's really precise it's
gonna make international trade way more
efficient and people were like oh this
is cool but like we're a little
skeptical and meanwhile in France they
were still kind of skeptical the current
leader at the time was this guy Napoleon
we've all heard about him and he was
super into it he's like metric is
awesome you know what else he was into
making sure everyone liked him so when
he saw that the French public wasn't
super jazzed about uprooting what was
working for them for like hundreds of
years he decided not to enforce metric
by law so France ended up in this weird
limbo for like 30 years and meanwhile
the U.S is like looking from across the
ocean and they're like dude metric it's
a total fad there's no way like Napoleon
is like wishy-washy there's no way this
is actually going to stick let's hold
off on the whole metric thing and just
industrialize with our very silly system
that is built on like people's feet the
metric system is the tour of the devil
my car gets 40 rods to the hotel and
that's the way I liked it but we'll get
back to the US in a minute because
there's still hope in the meantime
France finally gets fully on board and
successfully sells not only their public
on the metric system but the world
they're like come on guys we sent two
dudes out to do trigonometry with their
golden telescopes for like seven years
for this [ __ ] trust me you don't want to
do that on your own adopt the system it
was a tough sell at first to get people
to switch but eventually they did
started with Belgium then the
Netherlands and Luxembourg then Algeria
a French Colony 20 years later and then
it kind of snowballed from there partly
because countries realize how rational
it was but partly because Europe was
taking over the world at this time in
bringing their values and language and
systems to every corner of the globe
forcibly
colonialism will make it into everyone
okay but what about the USA well France
had some beef with the U.S at this point
it's kind of a long story not going to
go into it but what's important to know
is that the US was weirdly put in the
middle between this like Frenemy
Bromance gone wrong between France and
England so at First America wasn't
invited to the Inner Circle to be
introduced to metric but as the world
was adopting metric France finally
decided to send a guy over to deliver
this a prototype of the almighty Ultra
logical kilogram inviting the U.S to
join the rest of the world in this
measurement Revolution there is hope for
the USA to go metric
so this French ship is sailing across
the Atlantic with the kilogram on board
and a storm hits it and blows it into
the Caribbean where it runs into a group
of British Pirates the British Pirates
capture the Emissary from France they
imprison him and they try to gain Ransom
from France for this guy well they end
up accidentally killing the French guy
but they noticed that he has a package
and the Pirates are like oh [ __ ] this is
addressed to the U.S Secretary of State
Thomas Jefferson us Brits are cool with
the us right now so let's bring this
over to New York and deliver it super
courteous Pirates I like these guys but
when they get to New York Thomas
Jefferson isn't the Secretary of State
anymore so they just hand it to the guy
who is now the Secretary of State Edmund
Randolph and Randolph's like what the
hell is this weird hunk of copper so
then he gives it to this other guy who
just keeps it
so yeah thanks to geopolitics and
Pirates the US didn't get the kilo in
time to convince them to maybe adopt
France's new super logical system of
measurement Britain also refused for a
long time sticking with the system that
was developed using some dude's foot but
eventually they got on board but not
fully they still dabble in some weird
old Imperial ways but get this they've
changed some of the Imperial things
since the us became independent like
their pint which is like 25 percent
bigger than the Pint here they're both
called the Pint but go get a pint of
beer in the UK and you're actually
getting four ounces more than you would
in the U.S as if having one highly
illogical unreliable measuring system
including feet and teaspoons isn't bad
enough there are now two of them
floating around that have the same names
it gets real bad when you look at the
ounce which is a word that is used to
define several different units of mass
weight or volume same word bunch of
different things
okay okay but how hard can this be this
is my home turf this is my measurement
system
I got this
so when ounce in the UK is 120th an
imperial pint that seems nice and easy
that's 160th of an imperial gallon
approximately that's approximately
28.41 milliliters kind of gross okay
that's the Imperial fluid ounce used in
the UK okay so then the US ounce is 1 16
of a U.S liquid pint which is 128th of a
liquid gallon which is exactly 29.57
35295625 milliliters making it about
4.08 larger than the Imperial fluid the
ounce used in the UK okay but wait this
is just the fluid ounce what about the
weight ounce the one that came from like
the 7 000 grains to be a pound so it's 7
000 grains to a pound and there's 16
ounces to that pound so that's 437.5
grains to an ounce but if I want to
convert the weight ounce to the fluid
ounce I just need to multiply the volume
by
1.043176 times the density of the
ingredient or material so that we can
easily switch between the fluid ounce
and the weight ounce and the pound with
the 700 000 grains and sixteenth there's
1 16 of a pound is the ounce the grains
are 427.5 just convert it with Google
and you got it just super easy
ah yeah that's where we're at it's a
total mess you know how many
every country on Earth adopted the
metric system eventually besides these
three countries the US Myanmar and
Liberia United States just gave the rest
of the world big thing as they've built
metric system over the years the US has
attempted really formally to go metric
like in the 70s and 80s there was all
these debates and there was boards
created by the government to find a way
to like migrate over to metric but of
course Ronald Reagan shut it down
because of you know that cult government
spending thing this was an actual public
debate like this documentary I keep
showing was from a like PSA trying to
convince people to like get on board
with metric and then on the other side
in the 80s there was this anti-metric
group yes anti-metric groups that was a
thing they even hosted a gala where they
featured the most beautiful foot contest
didn't you just love American culture
just love to stick it to people just
look at us being individuals in our own
way but this stuff actually matters okay
in 1999 NASA sent a satellite to Mars
and it went off course and burned up in
the planet's atmosphere all because of a
misconversion between units of measure
one of the contractors was using
imperial units while NASA ground was
using metric and it ended up costing
NASA 125 million dollars but what's
interesting is that the US has kind of
secretly quietly got on board with
metric but it's just sort of behind the
scenes in boring sectors that none of us
really think about and that don't
actually make it into all of our
intuitions it's like industry or the
federal government or like nutrition
labels I don't look at nutrition labels
but if I did
I would see grams
and milligrams
and on liquid-based things I would say
milliliters
because nutrition labels are in metric
it doesn't matter that I don't really
know what a gram or a kilogram or a
milligram even is but when I go to the
pharmacy the pharmacist gives me my
medicine in milligrams progress
so yeah it's Pharmaceuticals it's
nutrition it's film it's tools it's
bicycles it's running races oh and for
some reason this one highway sign in
Arizona for all of these efforts none of
them have succeeded in getting metric
into the brains of everyday people like
me and this is why I will never use the
metric system I can't I literally cannot
you don't realize how your intuition is
calibrated in certain systems of
measurements until you try to change it
I started traveling in my early 20s
really for the first time abroad and I
saw them using metric and I saw how easy
it was and how rational it was and I
made a commitment to myself I'm like I'm
gonna change from my Imperial intuition
to adopting metric and I even swore like
I'm going to teach my future children
metric from an early age and since then
over a decade I have been trying I look
at this distance and to me oh that's 10
meters away not 30 feet it feels like
it's 20 degrees Celsius outside right
now I would say oh yeah it's like uh
five kilometers down the road oh I'm
gonna pick up two kilos of short rib to
make the soup tonight but my dirty
little secret is that I've totally been
faking it
10 meters doesn't mean anything to me
what it means is 30 feet divided by
three
what I've really been doing this whole
time is intuitively estimating Things
based on the system I know which is
pegged to farming activities and body
parts and then doing the rough math
based on the numbers I know about
converting to metric without those
conversion numbers
I honestly cannot estimate what 50
meters looks like I can't grasp what
running five kilometers feels like I
don't know what 22 centimeters is
outside of the context of a one foot
long ruler that I know is 30 centimeters
and so I'll never use the metric system
I don't know how and I can't teach
myself I've tried but then I had kids
there is hope the next Generation I
vowed to instill them with metric
intuition and found that it's basically
been impossible because everything
they're exposed to at school in math on
road trips while we're driving all of it
is in feet and miles and cups and Pints
and teaspoons and tons I mean I try I I
tell my kid measurements in like meters
and my six-year-old will literally
respond with well how far is that in
feet he is six like this isn't happening
the ship has sailed on changing to
metric here in the US for everyday
people it'll likely never happen I'm
trapped in a system that was developed
using people's body parts and farming
activities and King Henry's arm
we interrupt this film to bring you a
special bulletin from metric news
as America moves towards the metric
system the last holdouts have been seen
finally switching over soon it is
predicted the whole world will be
unified under this easier system of
measurement